un homme intègre pour certains un
président gênant pour d'autres thomas
sankara ces quatre années à la tête du
burkina faso de 1983 à 1987 et un surnom
celui du che guevara africain vous vous
sentez isolé
mal compris en tout cas
août 1983 à 33 ans thomas sankara arrive
au pouvoir après un coup d'état mené par
son ami blaise compaoré à peine ou
pouvoir le révolutionnaire veut rompre
avec le passé la corruption politique
c'est terminé lui-même vie simplement
avec sa famille dans un palais
présidentiel délabré et pour son
gouvernement la vie de luxe ce n'est
même pas la peine d'y penser fini les
mercedes aujourd'hui les ministres
roulant r5 et sans chauffeur autre
changement est d'importance en 1985 le
chef de l'état modifie le nom de la
haute volta place au burkina faso
pourquoi thomas sankara en expliquer la
raison en 1986 et c'est un nom qui ne
nous renvoie quand même passé
colonialiste par contre burkina faso
d'un an puiser dans nos terroirs même
qui a une signification dans notre
langue qui veut dire pas dessus des
hommes honnêtes thomas sankara multiplie
les mesures ils lancent des campagnes de
vaccination pour l'autosuffisance
alimentaire
même ses hommes vont récolter les champs
il faut qu'on ait un air assez à manger
tu voi manger il faut que tu sois
autre combat l'émancipation des femmes
thomas sankara est un précurseur en
afrique et féministe son gouvernement
crée une semaine de la femme demande
d'honneur à chaque femme l emploi nous
devons donner à chaque femme le moins de
gagner rôle de l'état et dilma saby et
thomas sankara est aussi critiquée
notamment à l'étranger des autres chefs
d'état africains se méfie de lui ne
veulent pas d'une révolution dans leur
pays avec françois mitterrand les
relations sont tendues le président
français n'apprécie pas du tout le
discours anticolonialiste de son
homologue burkinabé et il lui fait
savoir en 1986 mais c'est un homme un
peu dérangeant un président sankara
non c'est vrai il vous dit et
il pose des questions quoi un an plus
tard le 15 octobre 1987 thomas sankara
est tué par un commando lors d'un coup
d'état
34 ans après les faits le procès des
auteurs présumés du meurtre de l'ancien
révolutionnaire s'est ouvert à
ouagadougou sur le banc des 14 accusés
l'ancien ami intime de thomas sankara
blaise compaore
[Musique]